VIVIAN LUM: Discovery
and user retention
are two key problems developers
like you have to solve,
whether you're building
mobile apps or websites.
Fragmentation across
platforms unfortunately
makes the situation
worse because you
as a developer just
don't have the time
to solve those same problems
for Android, iOS, and the web.
My name is Vivian Lum.
Today, I will introduce several
search features and tools
that will simplify your life
and help you get more users get
more re-engagement.
First, let me
refresh your memory
about what we covered in our
last search DevByte video.
You learned that app indexing
can drive re-engagement
because with your
content indexed,
users can navigate directly
from Google Search results
into your app.
It works for users who
have installed your app,
but let's say I do not have
your app installed on my Android
phone.
Can Google still help me as
a user find apps like yours?
The answer is yes.
With app indexing,
Google can tell me
about the apps that contain
relevant content I'm
searching for.
And best of all, I can easily
install them right away.
For a while, when I
told some of my friends
I worked on app
indexing at Google,
they immediately asked if
it works for their iPhones.
Now, with app indexing
for iOS, Google
can help iPhone users get
to relevant in-app content
through the same deep
linking technology.
So how do you get your app and
its content found on Google?
First, you need to make your
app deep linkable by setting up
deep links in your app.
What are deep links?
Deep links are like
URLs for your app.
It is what makes your in-app
content indexable by Google.
Next, you need to link
your website to your app
so Google knows that a
given web URL actually
has a corresponding
app deep link,
and here's how you can
annotate the link pairs.
Besides building mobile apps,
many cross-platform developers
also maintain mobile websites.
Suppose you do.
How do you get your mobile
website found on Google, then?
We encourage you to first start
with our Mobile Friendly Test
to check out your website's
mobile friendliness,
and then follow our tips
on Webmaster Mobile Guide
to make your mobile website
more search friendly.
Alongside app indexing, which
helps Google surf the content
inside your app, you can
also broadcast the types
of interactions
your app supports
using a type of structure
data markup called
schema.org actions.
For example, watch a TV
show, stream a video,
play classical music.
What are schema.org
actions, then?
Think of it as a
way to declare what
your content is how and where
users can interact with it.
Together with Google
Voice Actions,
it doesn't matter
whether a search is
done using text or voice,
and Google can easily
help users looking for
specific piece of content
to also discover
capabilities of your app.
Let me give you an example.
As a working mom, I found
myself always quite busy.
So when I get a chance to
relax, my favorite thing to do
is to lounge on a couch, enjoy
a great movie or a TV show.
The problem is I usually just
know the name of the show
and have no time to research
or whatsoever whether it's
worth my time or not.
So I need to know if a show is
any good, where I can watch it.
OK, Google.
"Seinfeld."
With critic reviews
and watch actions,
not only can I learn
more about a show,
I can also find out
where to stream it.
So if you have an app
with streamable content,
how do you promote content
and actions on Google?
Just add a few lines of
markup to your website
and tells us exactly
where it can be
watched, what can be watched.
The show is now over, and
I'm ready to take a bath
and go to bed.
Hmm.
Bubble bath with some
relaxing music would be nice.
OK, Google.
Play music on Tunein.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Which genre
would you like to listen to?
VIVIAN LUM: Classical.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Playing classical.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIVIAN LUM: With
voice interaction API,
your app can get
selection input from users
to help them complete a task.
You can also close the
feedback loop with Google
by telling us completion
statuses using app indexing API
we launched a few months ago.
Finally, after completing any
integration research, what's
more important to a developer
than seeing the actual impact?
Whether you're a web
or app developer,
you can simply log
on to Search Console
to see the traffic driven
to you from Google Search.
Wow.
There are indeed a lot of new
ways for you to get more users
and keep them engaged.
Let me recap the steps.
One, to get found on Google you
need to set up your deep links
and link your
website to your app.
Two, to promote on
Google, you need
to annotate your
content and actions
and integrate with our APIs.
By integrating
with Google Search,
your mobile app and website
can have a better chance
to be discovered and
used by your users.
To get started, check out
our developers website
at g.co/developersearch.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]